CARTER MORGAN: Hi,
I'm Carter Morgan,
and today I'm going to share how
Google Cloud AppSheet can help
empower citizen
developers to build
their own no-code applications.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Have you spent countless hours
sifting through an endless list
of out-of-the-box solutions,
frustrated that nothing is
quite what you'd
hope it would be?
Do you ever think
to yourself, I know
what I need to be
successful, I wish
I could just build it myself?
If so, no need to
look any further.
No-code solutions like Google
Cloud AppSheet is democratizing
technology, allowing everyone,
everywhere-- including you--
to become a citizen
developer that
creates custom applications
to meet your unique needs.
This means that by
leveraging the power of data,
non-technical individuals can
build their own applications
without even needing to know
how to write a line of code.
By expanding the pool of who can
access app development from 10
million software engineers to
more than 2 billion people,
AppSheet is helping increase
the number of people who
can provide a quick solution.
With the right no-code
platform in place,
this newfound talent pool
of citizen developers
can help their companies ideate
quickly, drive innovation,
and increase agility in an
ever changing work environment.
But how exactly
does AppSheet work?
Well, it engages with your data,
and through Machine Learning,
processes the
information in the data
and creates application that can
be used on desktops, for those
in the office, or
on mobile devices,
for those in the field.
You can think about
no-code behaving
like a self-driving car.
These self-driving
platforms allow
you to describe to them
where you want to go,
and AppSheet will
drive you there.
In this case, your data
is the description.
And certain data points, like
dates or email addresses,
influence how your application
looks, feels, and behaves.
There are three key areas of
no-code development that set
AppSheet apart in
the no-code space--
governance, AI & ML
capabilities, and automation.
For now, we're going to provide
a quick walk-through that
showcases how
Google AI & ML help
you get started with AppSheet
in just a few clicks.
Let's get started.
First, we're going to
authorize your data source.
On the AppSheet home page,
click the Start for Free button.
You'll be taken to a screen that
states Start with Your Data.
Select your cloud-based
data source-- in this case,
we'll be using
our Google Drive--
and authorize your account
to work with AppSheet.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Your data will not be moved.
It will remain with your
preferred data source.
Once you've authorized
your data source,
you will be taken to
your account page.
For a quick start,
click Make a New App,
and select Start
with Your Own Data.
Next, provide a name
for your application
and select the type of
application you want to build.
For this app, let's build
a field service inspection
application.
Click Select Data, and
select from the list
of authorized data sources.
Select the appropriate
file for your application,
and then let Google's Machine
Learning analyze your data
and make smart suggestions
based on the type of data
and your source.
In this survey app, AppSheet
made recommendations
for views of maps
and image gallery
and forms based on your data.
From here, you can customize
how your application looks
and behaves, add
automation, and decide
who you'd like to share
your application with.
The emulator on the right
provides real-time updates
and different screen types
to the changes you're making,
so you can iterate on
your application quickly.
From the complex
solutions to simple forms,
the possibilities
are endless for what
can be accomplished with a
no-code platform like AppSheet.
Ready to start building a custom
line of business solutions
that will empower your team?
Get started today by clicking
the link in the description
below.
Happy app building.
[MUSIC PLAYING]